αλλά τα αυτό χρονατ το σκουλούκι που λέμεν η παλιά ρόστια τις διποσιογραφείας πολιτικής είναι
πάντα εκεί η δηλαδή είναι πάνταστοικώνια και σε περιμένει θαμε στη συνέχεια και για το
νέωσοβιβλίο αλλάκαινα τηνόχυμεπέρασ μασω από το χωρό των μύτια ξεκαινούμε λίγο από τα κόμματα γιατί
πιστερεις αντριάμο ότι σήμερα τα παραδωσια κάμεγάλα κόματα έχουν αυτή τηπτωτική τάσει που παρουσιάζουν κάποιας
δημοσκόποιες που αρουσιάστηκαντελευταας ητάξει νομίζω ότι είναι αδικώ να απομονώνουμε το τη συμβαίνει στα κόματα
από το τη συμβαίνει στην πολύπη κοινωνί υπάρχειτθονικωστών πρώτο νεώνανίαν θέλεις ιδύω μετά το δύο
χιλιά το δύο χιάς δέκα και μετά οι ανατρωπές που συμβαίνουν παγκοσμείως με κρία ρχον
ένα υσμάτης την τεχτην τεχνολογική εξέλιξη το γεγολώσε ότι ξαφνικά εκεί που είχαμε ένα κίίνητων
τηλέφωνω για να μιλούμε έχουμε ένα κινητών τηλέφωνον που κάνει τα πάντα δηλαδή μα παιανι
τω σιγμόν ξερείπό σαβήματα έκαμαμε την ημέρα τομας τ που κοινούμας αγριβοός διλαδή όπου και
να σε στον κόσμον θέλει σταξί παταστογού περιτοπόλτ παταστοφούτι κες ουφέρνει χαγιτών ολά αυτά τα
πράγματα έχουν τις επιπτώσεις του στον τρόπο με των οποίο συμπεριφέρεται ο πολί της καταναλωτής
αρά η ψηφοφόρος όπως θεαναλόγως τ πιαστα αιδιότητα θέλειτς διαλέγεις σε κάθε περίπτως συνεπως τα
κόμματα όπως και άλλη οργανισμεί αλλά τα κόματα κατακύριο λόγο δύοτι είναι πρώταγώνιστέ είναι μπροστά
στην κοινωνία δεν εμπορέσαν να βρούν και όχει μόνο στην κύπρο σε όλον των κόσμον
της συνταγιντομιστικώντο κληδί που θα ξεκληδώσει τη παλλιά πόρτα και θα τους ανοίξει την καινούργια
για να πουν στη νέα επορχή άρα βλέπουμε α διστην ελλάδαν είδαμε το φαινόμενον του
πασόκ του κυρίαρχου να καταλίγεις ε μόνο ψήφιους και τώρα να επανέρχεται ως ταξεικ